cold emails do work you find the angel
investors email address which isn't that
difficult and if you can't find an angel
investors email address well maybe you
shouldn't be in the business cuz not the
hardest thing in the world and you can
also find these people on angel list now
and Twitter and Facebook and LinkedIn so
the angel investors are out there you
just have to do the research so
contacting them by email it's delicate
because they get a lot of emails what
will they respond to well I'll give you
a couple of hints if you start out with
a compliment
and/or recognition that you know the
history of that angel investor you are
going to start off on second base
literally so if you're emailing navall
from AngelList
who is an angel investor as well and you
say I knew your first company or I saw
your interview with Jason on this week
in startups and you said this and it
inspired me to become an entrepreneur or
dear Jason I am a huge fan of episode
number 206 with Chris Sacca he was
hilarious but I really loved Gary
Vaynerchuk Chuck's episode best right
you're starting with some indication
that you've done your research on the
angel which makes us as the Angels know
I'm not just one out of 200 emails you
sent the cookie cutter and send it in a
regular normal font but I got an email
the other day from somebody got a really
interesting idea for some reason they
decided to like HTML their email and
also if it's too long if it's really
long it doesn't look like like a sane
person doesn't write a thousand words in
a first email so here's what your first
demos should say dear ex angel investor
I really am interested in what you said
in this article and/or podcast I agree
with a book that's like one sentence
sentence - I am a 27 year old graduate
of Stanford who is working on an idea
one sentence description of the idea
that's it just a little taste of who you
are we don't need your goddamn life
biography because nobody cares if it
carrots what school you went to but a
little bit okay I'm a 26 year old from
Manhattan I'm 22 I'm in Chicago
what I'm dealing with here people do
want to know it could be I'm at 30 I
don't mean to be ages here but it could
be I'm a 30-year vet of the television
industry and have left to start an
advertising network for youtubers here's
how it works one sentence right just
here's what I'm doing one sentence then
here's the magic a link a screenshot
just something that indicates that you
are a builder a talker not a walker
nobody is interested in your ideas we're
interested in your execution for the
love of God nobody cares about your
ideas I don't know how to say that more
plainly if you are an angel investor a
professional investor do you know what
you hear all day long
ideas do you know what you realize after
a very short period of time everybody
has the same goddamn ideas oh you want
to make a social network that's better
than MySpace mr. Zuckerberg wow I have
gotten that actually I have gotten that
idea literally 500 times in the last six
months I'm putting us back in that time
period when Zach was you know coming out
and raising capital and leaving Harvard
to come to Palo Alto
but what differentiated somebody like
mr. Zuckerberg is that mr. Zuckerberg
was a talk was not a talker but a walker
he was a doer okay he could show
something here it is here is the basic
version here's how it works right he had
started building and there was a sense
of inevitability
you either got on the Facebook train or
you didn't and trust me that train was
moving fast there was a sense of urgency
to it so that is how you contact
somebody cold email and then at the
bottom so we got the first paragraph
about the angel investor second
paragraph who you are in your idea and
then three an image a mock-up a URL that
takes them to a deck whatever it is and
then number four I would love to meet
with you anytime anywhere for 15 minutes
if you are interested in what I'm doing
so you've basically now you've sent
another signal
I will go anywhere at any time to get
ten minutes with you that's how
important you are mr. Duvall
okay mr. Chris Dixon miss mrs. Esther
Dyson whoever it is that you're trying
to get as an angel investor you want to
make them feel like this is the most you
are the most important angel investor
for them to land even if it's not true
you need to make them feel special and
now they will not respond to your first
one but they may click on the link they
may look at the images you know why
screens like to move people like to see
things moving on their screen when you
send somebody a screenshot or a
wireframe I mean and you don't don't
send everything right you don't send the
whole goddamn site map and a huge 50
page document that's absurd but if you
just send if you just send us a
beautiful image we are gonna look at it
we cannot help but not look at it now
you say to me well I don't have a
designer
why are you coming to angel investors if
you're not even capable in the year of
2014 of getting a world-class designer
to build you a couple of screens for the
love of God a world-class designer on
dribble or Behance net cost 25 50 75 or
$100 an hour if you're not willing to
spend a thousand dollars with a designer
you should not be writing that email and
this is a whole nother thing that I'm
gonna get into firing off emails is easy
that's why I get so many goddamn him all
time that's why all of us angel
investors get so many emails but making
something beautiful and crafting it and
thinking it through is hard so if you
send an email you put yourself in the
bucket of people book a park a pible of
sending an email guess what that's 100
percent of the population can send an
email but if you make something crafted
and brilliant small but brilliant and
beautiful
you've now self selected yourself into
the top 10% of the class by spending
$500,000 but you know what 95% of people
email we don't even take that basic step
and I can tell you 95% of 100 don't take
the basic step to understand who they're
emailing and if you sense a little bit
of frustration in my voice it's because
as an angel investor and an entrepreneur
I've been on both sides of the table
and I thought this for myself I made
these mistakes early in my career where
I was just like if I could just go to
lunch with you if I could just get time
with you you would understand that I'm
brilliant it might be true but we need
to have a filtering mechanism on the
other side of the table and the
filtering mechanism depending on who you
are is going to be execution maybe their
network okay and it's and it's a very
simple maybe how good your idea is maybe
but I doubt it it's really gonna be did
you come from a trusted source or did
you make something brilliant and that
and that leads me the next point the
best way to get in touch with me is not
to give email me it's to find somebody I
trust and to get them to introduce you
and to send your email to me so I just
got the co-founder of YouTube who I one
of the cofounders just three actually in
the third little-known co-founder email
me about a project and he said hey Jason
we've you know you may not remember we
may have made of course I remembered him
and he said I'm investing in this these
individuals who have this idea that's in
the video space would love to meet with
you and I said well if they know the
co-founder of YouTube and they're in the
video business and they got him to email
me you know what I'm like halfway there
to invest thinking about taking the
meeting I instantly replied with my
assistant get a meeting let's talk and I
didn't even really I mean I did click on
the idea it had a link there they did
explain their ideas so singly
but it was just a perfect perfect
interaction for me as an entrepreneur